Speaker 1: So one of the really common sort
of oxymoronic phenomena that we see in American
politics is that the people that you sometimes
see most loudly shouting about how the Constitution
says, I get to do something or the Constitution
says you don't get to do something or you
don't get to force me to do something.
The people most loudly shouting that type
of stuff are often the people who least understand
the Constitution.
We've seen this with free speech.
We've we've talked to First Amendment experts
about how the people most loudly and most
frequently yelling about free speech and the
First Amendment actually don't understand
it.
In the covid era, in the pandemic era, that
same constitutional confusion, as we might
call it, applies to vaccination very, very
of analogously.
And more and more, we're hearing that, listen,
it's in the Constitution.
You don't have to get vaccinated if you don't
want to.
You can't violate my constitutional rights
by forcing me to get vaccinated.
We hear that any vaccine mandate would be
a violation of your constitutional rights
and this actually couldn't be more wrong.
Now, I want to be really clear, because sometimes
when we do a conversation like this, people
wrongly think I'm saying something that I'm
not actually saying.
The issue of the legality of vaccine mandates
in general by a government is a topic of much
legal discussion.
And there isn't 100 percent agreement about
could the federal government mandate a vaccine
versus would it have to be done at the state
level or whatever the case may be.
But it is not a constitutional issue, period.
And there's actually precedent which we will
talk to talk about in a moment so we can make
a moral case for a vaccination requirement.
But that's not actually what this is about.
We could make a cultural or a public health
case for a vaccination requirement.
But again, that's not actually today's topic.
There is no constitutional case.
Against vaccine requirements, so let's go
through the likely arguments that the anti
Baxters would make along these grounds, they
might say a vaccine mandate violates the First
Amendment to the Constitution.
They might say a vaccine mandate violates
the Fifth Amendment to the Constitution.
And sometimes they say a vaccine mandate would
violate the 14th Amendment to the Constitution.
Now, the First Amendment protects speech,
the fifth religion and the 14th, the right
not to be, quote, deprived of life, liberty
or property without due process of law.
I don't believe any of these would hold up.
But this is not a show where I give legal
opinions I come up with because legal is not
my area of expertize.
My assessment is just what do the legal opinions
say about exactly this issue?
And I've told you before that in the early
20th century there was a legal controversy
over vaccine mandates not dissimilar to the
one we're seeing today.
And it took place in Massachusetts and it
was surrounding smallpox.
And the Supreme Court decided in 1985 against
a guy who refused to get the smallpox vaccine.
The Supreme Court decided that the state's
vaccine requirement, the City of Cambridge's
vaccine requirement, was perfectly fine, saying
that your liberty stops at its likelihood
to damage or do harm to other people.
It's actually a relatively simple concept,
even in libertarian circles, sane libertarian
circles.
This is the case of Jacobsson v. Massachusetts.
You can Google the case.
There's a very simple wiki article explaining
what it's all about.
So there is Supreme Court precedent for enforcing
vaccine mandates.
That ruling from nineteen five has been referenced
repeatedly, even in the covid era, even in
the Soviet era by the Supreme Court when vaccine
requirements have been upheld.
This 19 five case has been referenced.
Now, in terms of speech, generally, the government
can prohibit behavior that is generally protected
by the First Amendment if it is demonstrably
to save lives, to preserve life.
And the infamous kind of prototypical example
is the government can ban yelling fire in
a crowded theater, even though speaking and
saying the word fire generally is protected
speech speaking is protected speech.
But this is a case where the government can
actually say you can't do that.
And people might say, but, sir, that's my
free speech that goes beyond free speech.
It goes into public safety.
And the fact that yelling fire in a crowded
theater is likely much like a ton of people
refusing to get vaccinated, to have a predictable,
deleterious, harmful effect on public health
and on people.
Now, there is another issue here, which I
think I should mention, and it's the issue
of hypocrisy.
There is almost always hypocrisy from these
right wingers, my body, my choice on the vaccine.
Same with a woman's right to choose right
now.
Oh, no, no, no.
That should be illegal.
It's that one that's a double standard.
And we'll talk tomorrow about what's going
on with the Texas abortion law.
And here with the case of the vaccines, many
of those opposing the vaccine mandates, because
it's government overreach, had no problem
with the Patriot Act, NDAA, mass surveillance,
etc.
The same people who have been fighting for
decades for businesses to have all the power
and the employees to have none, suddenly want
to take away the right of a business to say,
hey, our business decision is that our employees
have to be vaccinated.
Our business decision, which conservatives
have said for decades we should have we should
be able to make decisions that are best for
us.
Our decision is customers must be vaccinated
all of a sudden.
Now they're against that.
So, yes, they're pathetic.
Yes, they are hypocrites, but they're also
wrong on the facts.
And that's a unique combination, pathetic,
hypocritical and wrong on the facts and on
the constitutionality of vaccination mandates.
You do not have a constitutional right not
to get vaccinated.
The details of vaccine mandates, if we see
them, are going to be adjudicated and will
handle them one by one.
But that blanket, it's almost used like a
cudgel that that's a violation of the Constitution,
really, which which part of the Constitution
or Bill of Rights.
And the arguments very, very quickly fall
apart.
We'll have more on this.
As I assume.
I expect maybe it is a better way to say.
I expect that there will be more legal decisions
about vaccination requirements and mandates
upcoming